into the seal you see in the middle of
the seal two words
excelsior state model ever upwards
aspirational we can be better we can
lift ourselves excelsior
and we added he pluribus unum which is
actually more appropriate today than
when we started this process a pourable
unum out of many one out of many one it
was a founding fathers fundamental
belief for this nation Adams spoke to it
Madison spoke to a Jefferson spoke to it
although they had a lot of different
opinions while they were doing the
Constitution the one thing they agreed
with was e pluribus unum out of many one
and it was good advice then it's even
better advice today the curve continues
to go up the number of tests has reached
a new high we did over 21,000 tests
thank you to our great health department
we have over 10,000 new cases 102
thousand total tested positive 14,000
hospitalized 3700 ICU patients 80 800
patients discharged that's good news
number of deaths highest single increase
in the number of deaths since we started
2,300 to 2900 deaths
you see the totality for New York State
102 thousand New Jersey California
remember when this started New York had
airports that were designated entry
zones this is an international
destination international hub we have
people coming from across the world
sooner and at a higher rate than anyone
else
total hospitalization 1,400 that's also
a new high daily ICU admissions is down
a little bit but you had more deaths you
have more people coming into hospitals
than any other night also more people
going out which is obviously the ebb and
the flow that's coming in and out of the
hospital system the hot spots we now
track on a nightly basis how many people
go into what facility so we can track
the increase in what's happening you see
an increase in New York City as we know
certain communities frankly more in New
York City than other communities but you
also see an increase on Long Island
which is something we're concerned about
Long Island does not have as elaborate a
health care system as New York City we
don't have the same amount of resources
on Long Island and we see an increase in
the number of cases on Long Island and
that has this very concerned supplies
PPE are in short supply as they are
across the country we need companies to
make the materials it is it is
unbelievable to me that in New York
State in the United States of America we
can't make these materials and that we
are all shopping China to try to get
these materials and we're all competing
against each other these are not complex
materials
and we will work with New York
manufacturers will finance the
transition necessary to make these
materials I mean we talk about them as
if they're very complicated this is an
n95 mask this is it it was 70 cents
before this started
so now as high as $7 but this is all
that an n95 mask is its fabric its
material the FDA has the specifications
and then it's two pieces of elastic cord
it can't be that we can't make these
this is a gown
we call them gowns this is a gown
there's nothing sophisticated about the
manufacturing of this garment not that
the grave the garment
there's nothin sophisticated about the
material it can't be bad companies in
this country and in this state can't
transition to make those supplies
quickly again I understand if there's a
financial burden we will address that
and we will work with you so please
contact us Javits is going to be
converted to a kovat facility the
original plan was to use Javits Javits
is a state convention center it was
retrofitted by the order of engineers to
hold 2,500 people the original plan was
that it would not take kovat patients
kovat positive patients it would take
non kovat patients and it would be an
overflow for hospitals as it turned out
we don't have non kovat people to any
great extent in the hospitals hospitals
have now turned into effectively ICU
hospitals for kovat patients so we
wanted to convert Javits from non kovat
to Kovac the it's federally run
frankly the federal agencies were not
eager to do that FEMA was not eager to
do that I called the president I spoke
to him about it yesterday morning that
afternoon yesterday afternoon the
president called me back said he spoke
to the task force they would grant the
request to transition the code the
Javits Center took over it only that is
adds 2,500 beds so that is a very big
deal and I thank the president for doing
it he did it despite the fact that the
federal agencies were not eager to do it
and he did it quickly so I thank him for
that it's a big deal for us we're still
challenging we still have the challenge
of ventilators we don't have enough
period this system is this situation is
very simple now people come in there
were almost all covered people
ironically
the number of non-covered cases has
dropped because so many things are shut
down that you don't have the same number
of automobile accidents so people
getting hit by cars you don't have the
same crime rate so you don't have the
same number of trauma cases coming into
a hospital they are covered cases and
many of them go right to the ICU in the
ICU you need a ventilator and if you
don't have a ventilator the process
stops and we don't have enough
ventilators we're doing everything
possible splitting of ventilators using
BiPAP machines by this new protocol
using the anesthesia ventilators we're
talking to the federal government to be
as helpful as they can from the federal
stockpile but in truth I don't believe
the federal stockpile has enough to help
all the states because you can't buy the
material at this point we're still
trying to buy from China we're working
with Alibaba which has been very very
helpful to us
I spoke to Jack Ma and Mike Evans who is
the president and they have been
personally gracious and very very
helpful in trying to get us the source
material from China but we're going to
have to redeploy ventilators from across
the system in other words there are
hospitals that have ventilators there
are hospitals that have PPE equipment
there are private sector companies that
have PPE equipment that they are not
using that we're going to need to
redeploy to the places and the hospitals
where we need them I had a conversation
with a hospital administrator yesterday
I understand they don't want to give up
their ventilators ventilators or
expensive pieces of equipment I
understand that even if they're not
using them they are reluctant to see
them go out the door the theory is if
they if the government gets them they'll
never get them back I understand that
but I don't have an option and I'm not
going to get into a situation where we
know where we are running out of
ventilators and we could have people
dying because there are no ventilators
but there are hospitals in other parts
of the state that have ventilators that
they're not using I'm just not going to
allow us to go there I think it would be
wholly irresponsible so I'm going to
sign an executive order that says the
state can take ventilators and PPE from
institutions that don't need them now
and redeploy them to other parts of the
state and other hospitals that do need
them those institutions will either get
the ventilator back or they will be
reimbursed and paid for their ventilator
so they can buy a new ventilator I can't
do anything more than that but I'm not
going to
in a position where people are dying and
we have several hundred ventilators in
our own state somewhere else I apologize
for the hardship to those institutions
ultimately there is no hardship if you
don't get the ventilator back I give you
my personal word I will pay you for the
ventilator but I'm not gonna let people
die because we didn't redistribute
ventilators the National Guard are going
to be deployed to pick up these
ventilators which are all across the
state and deploy them to places where we
need them state budget passed last night
3 a.m. as you know the state budget was
extraordinary
first it passed a lot of major policy
initiatives that we should all be very
proud of the nation's first domestic
terrorism law it improved bail reform it
addressed this child vaping scourge that
is going across this nation we banned
fentanyl a ban against repeat subway sex
offenders campaign finance reform paid
sick leave middle-class tax cut very
aggressive airport construction program
and accessible renewable energy siting I
understand we're all consumed with the
coronavirus situation but you have to be
able to walk and chew gum we have to
move forward at the same time and that's
why passing the budget and these pieces
of legislation were important because
these issues are still important and
child vaping etc surrogacy these are
major issues for people and they passed
last night and congratulations the
budget was difficult because the state
has no money and how do you do a budget
when you can't really forecast revenues
and we came up with a somewhat novel
budget that actually is calibrated to
future revenues or losses so we really
start with an assumption and then what
we're saying
is when we see how much revenue the
state makes how fast the economy comes
back what the expenses are we'll cut
will calibrate accordingly we are
heavily reliant on the federal aid
legislation that gets passed the the
federal government has passed a couple
of pieces of legislation they're
planning to pass another piece of
legislation it's very important that
whatever legislation they pass helps
state and local governments when you
deprive a state government all you are
actually achieving is that that state
government has to turn around and not
fund the programs that were dependent on
that state government we fund education
we fund health care
I spoke to speaker Pelosi today she's
working on the program for the next
piece of legislation she understands
fully the need of state governments she
understands fully the need of local
governments she understands my position
on how New York was shortchanged in the
past bill and she said she's going to do
everything she can do to help New York
I've worked with the speaker many times
I've known it for thirty years and I
believe her and her credibility and her
competence is unparalleled in my opinion
so I'll be working with the speaker and
the rest of the congressional delegation
going forward but we need federal
assistance depending on how much federal
assistance we get will be that
calibration of the budget going forward
coronavirus response in general there's
a lot of conversations about how we
should respond to this governmental or
from an inter governmental perspective
people want to say well this is a states
rights question versus federal
interference who should decide what's
done on a state level there is no
governor
who is arguing that their states rights
are being trampled right so it's not a
states rights issue no one is standing
up saying the federal government is
trampling my rights I've said that on
other occasions but no governor democrat
or republican is saying that here every
state is saying the same thing I need
help I need assistance so I don't
consider this situation where the
federal government is interfering with
the states right this is a situation
that is a by definition a national
disaster emergency situation where the
states need and welcome the federal
assistance I've done I was in the
federal government as you know I worked
on scores of federal emergencies the
only operational model that I see that
could potentially work here at this
stage where we are today with the
realities we're facing where no state
can get these supplies they need no
state can get the PPE they need no state
can get the ventilators they need the
marketers has literally collapsed the
only operational model that I see is you
have curves we've been talking about our
curve you have curves in different parts
of the country and those curves occur at
different times it depends on when the
outbreak started in that region how
quickly it spread so you have different
curves in different parts of the country
occurring at different times I think the
only practical solution at this point is
focus on the emergency that is in front
of you focus on the emergency at the
place and time that is in front of you
and then redeploy to the next situation
so New York
is the tip of the spear so to speak we
have the high numbers we have the first
major encounter deploy resources up to
New York well hit that curve we'll be at
the top of the curve 17 days 21 days
we're on the other side of the curve and
we're coming down and then I don't need
the ventilators that we've amassed and
split and the BiPAP machines we can
redeploy what we have personnel
equipment to whatever locality is next
now it's not a perfect sequential timing
but if you look at the projected curves
when it's going to hit Michigan when
it's going to hit Illinois when it's
going to hit Florida you'll see that
there is a timing sequence to it why not
or what is the alternative to now saying
let's help each other let's focus on
each situation as it develops and let's
move our resources and personnel as it
develops what is the alternative to the
crisis that we see looming nationwide
you can't you do not have enough the
federal government does not have enough
material to sit there and say whatever
you need I can get you don't worry
California don't worry Michigan don't
worry New York don't worry Florida they
can't they can't they have essentially
said I don't have enough in my stockpile
to handle all of this and then you get
into a blame game should it have been in
the federal stockpile should state
states have had stockpile forget that
the reality is how do you handle this
operationally unless you go from place
to place with the proviso that you say
and then each state has to help every
other state as we go
there is a simple analogy to this that
we live all the time when we have minor
emergencies or disasters when we have a
minor hurricane that's regional in
nature or minor flood power goes out
what do we do all the power and utility
companies from all across the country
descend on that region that means help
right after a hurricane power lines are
down you look at the highways you see
all those trucks coming in from
different states right
Arizona trucks Colorado trucks when
Florida has a hurricane what do we do we
get in the trucks everybody drives down
to Florida personnel etc when Puerto
Rico got into trouble what did we do con
Edison New York Rochester gas they all
went down to Puerto Rico
why because help the place that has the
crisis this is that on a macro scale New
York is in crisis help New York and then
pick up the camp and then go to the next
place as this rolls across the country
there's not a perfect timing there will
be two parts of the country that hit an
apex at the same time there will be
three parts of the country that hit an
apex at the same time but I do not see
any operation or operational practical
alternative to dealing with this going
forward and by the way this is all
operational there is no concept there's
no abstraction there's no philosophy to
this this is a person walks in the door
do you have a bed do you have a staff
person are they wearing PPE and do you
have a ventilator and are they all
present at that moment when that person
walks in that door that's all
Lissa's that's all this is forget
testing vaccines that's a separate
project that's not where people are
going to die in the near term people are
going to die in the near term because
they walk into a hospital and there's no
bed with a ventilator because there's
either no bed or no staff or no PPE or
no ventilator that is what is going to
happen and I think this is the only way
to avoid it and look I believe the
American people are there you know how
many times have we seen a disaster
across this country and how many
Americans just show up to help I mean
it's in the American DNA to say we're
here to help one another it is e
pluribus unum I didn't have to put that
on the seal that's just a reminder out
of many one where community where
Americans we're a family we're brothers
and sisters there's a commonality while
I'm a New Yorker you're from California
I know those are lines on a piece of
paper we are the same we're the same and
we know that here in New York I asked
for people to come help New York
health officials health professionals
20,000 people volunteered in a matter of
days to come help New York in the middle
of a pendant 20,000 people think about
that 20,000 health professionals said
I'll leave my home and come to your
state systematize that volunteerism
systematize that generosity that charity
and that expertise and that's how we
beat this damn virus as it marches
across the country we just deploy in
front of the virus as it as it works its
way across the country
in any event when our curve is over
that's what we are going to do new
yorkers are going to take what we've
amassed we're going to take our
equipment we're going to take our
personnel we're going to take our
knowledge and we will go to any
community that needs help we're learning
things that fortunately no other
community had to learn because we're
first and because of the intensity of
the situation here when our urgent need
is over we will help any community in
this nation that needs it because that
outpouring has been there for us you
know I remember post 9/11 and I remember
post 9/11 without asking anyone for
anything the people who showed up in New
York just to help tradesmen bringing
tools people bringing food people
bringing trays of cookies whatever they
just showed up nobody asked they just
showed up and said I'm here to help or
stood on the corner helping people
that's America at its best and at this
time when we're dealing with our worst
let's deploy America at its best
and we know what that is and that can
help us questions comments
dr. Zuber so there's there's no data to
support the effectiveness of a face mask
and I understand that usually we'd like
to have face things on evidence and
unfortunately difficult times like this
we have to go with expert opinion and
right now the data doesn't there isn't
data to suggest whether mask except for
those who are ill and those who are
health care workers and that's why we're
reserving those for health care workers
well the the evidence that like I was
saying that there's no clear evidence to
suggest that face masks whether me out
of cloth or even whether general public
using face masks but would continue to
look at the data all the time that's
coming in and we're examining that right
now
I think it's let me ask the doctor for a
qualified opinion I think it's fair to
say the masks couldn't hurt unless they
gave you a false sense of security
you know when a doctor talks about a
mask they're talking about a
form-fitting mask that goes around your
nose that doesn't allow any other air to
come in that's really what a mask is so
to ask a doctor does a bandana help I
said to the doctor inside I said you
know I'll just get the bandanas that I
wear when I ride my motorcycle
he was like yeah that's not going to
happen
the this is what the doctor thinks of as
a mask right but could it hurt might it
help I think it's fair to say yes but
don't get a full sense of security that
now you don't have to social distance
and you don't have to take the normal
precautions because you're wearing a
bandana is that fair to say
yes first of all don't use the word
seize I didn't use that word that's a
harsh kind of word it's sharing of
resources we're going to share resources
we're not going to have any part of the
state that doesn't have the resources
they need because we didn't share
resources we are tracking every night
every hospital who comes in what they
have what they need and we're just
sharing and shifting resources which is
the only intelligent thing to do among
one group of people right now the
numbers in upstate New York are lighter
than the numbers in downstate New York
but that is going to change it is in New
York City now you're seeing Long Island
start to light up we had Westchester
light up numbers are growing in Erie
you're gonna see that wave move through
the state you've been watching it every
day on that map as every state every
county is now colored in we're going to
shift the resources all across the state
to whatever place has that need at that
time and we're going to make sure every
hospital has the resources they need to
do the normal business what is
fascinating is the normal business has
dropped off dramatically for a hospital
why we canceled all elective surgery so
elective non-critical surgeries not
happening and when we closed down most
of society and people are staying home
less people are getting hurt less
bicycle accidents less crime so
hospitals who are not dealing with kovat
are seeing very low at
and it's not that we're going to leave
any healthcare facility without adequate
equipment but they don't need excess
equipment now right most of these
hospitals put together stockpile you
know you'll have 50,000 masks well
50,000 masks how long does that last you
five months it lasts me
okay you don't really need a five month
supply right now keep a one month supply
give me four months and it got pretty
bad you need it because there's a
problem I'll read the ploy it the other
way otherwise I owe you four months
worth of masks and I will pay you for we
have to see how many we haven't done
that calculation Jesse so if a hospital
has we have to go hospital by hospital
how many do you have how many do you
need for the immediate future there
could be several hundred excess
ventilators in hospitals that don't have
a covetous Ponce right now it's a number
several hundred could represent several
hundred lives so am I willing to deploy
the National Guard and inconvenience
people for several several hundred lives
you're damn right I am
several hundred ventilators doesn't fix
the problem obviously but it's it's a
significant number of ventilators when
you can't find ventilators anywhere else
and you've done everything else that you
can do
yes yes well let's do it this way let's
do it this way you're burning about the
burn rate is about 300 ventilators per
day if you find 300 excess ventilators
you found another day look you it's
human nature right let me borrow let me
borrow your equipment no I'd rather keep
my equipment here government is gonna
take it how do I know I get it back how
do I track it it's an expensive piece of
equipment by the way a ventilator is now
well now it's like fifty thousand
dollars when we started it was about
twenty thousand dollars so it's not like
asking to borrow a cup of sugar
you know you think they might sue me it
would be a slow day if I didn't get sued
five times John but if they want to sue
me for borrowing their excess
ventilators to save lives let them sue
me yes it'll stand up I'll borrow them I
will return them or I will pay you for a
new one
you wanna hope I don't return it so I
pay you for a new one
lend me your drill I will bring it back
to you or I will buy you a new drill how
do you lose
I'm not I'm not taking your last drill
you have five other drills in your
toolbox
you're not going to use five drills
between now and then and if something
happens where you're going to drilling
frenzy call me and I will bring you more
drills it will have ICU beds I don't
know the mix between the well ICU bed
for intensive for all intensive purposes
in this conversation
it's a ventilated bed right so how many
ventilators we'll be in Javits it's
federally staffed they're going to have
to find the ventilators for it
so it's going to be up to them that
would be from their stockpile yes look
we have the situation all across the
board we have TWU workers transit
workers who have a very high rate of
illness and who by the way are doing
heroic work and I want to thank them
very much John Samuelson the transit
workers union these to run those trains
run those buses every day talk about
social distancing you you're a bus
driver right it's hard to social
distance you're a train conductor
pulling into stations all across the
city
so these they're doing heroic work very
high rate of illness that's a problem
it's a problem in the NYPD it's a
problem in the FDNY it's a problem all
across the board it's a problem serious
problem with health care workers nurses
and hospital staff so it'll be on a
case-by-case basis Bernadette you know
we'll look to the localities we have the
same situation in Nassau and Suffolk by
the way we look to the locality what do
they think is a level where they need
backup and then we'll do everything we
can to provide backup no you couldn't do
a state takeover the NYPD I would be of
assistance to helping the NYPD we have
to perform a policing function right
that's state constitution provide public
safety the NYPD if they have a serious
staff shortage then I would work with
them to figure out how we remedy that
but the NYPD is something like 30,000
employees there is no replacing 30,000
employees
does anybody know that we have
transferred over the course of the last
two days
several dozen patients backup to this
area and we working closely with the
hospital's down there
yeah I did not speak to the president
about the comfort in any depth the
comfort the original agreement on the
comfort the ship was it was for non
colvett people I think the Navy I'm
going to speak to the Secretary of
Defense the Navy position is they don't
want to put covert people on the ship
because it would be too hard to
disinfect the ship afterwards that's my
rough interpretation of what they are
saying I've not heard that well we only
have Kovac and non Kovac patients right
and the the need is really for the kovat
patients I know they're not taking Kovac
positive patients but they said that
from day one
in fairness now I don't know the the
science of ship disinfecting to know
whether or not they're being overly
dramatic but I'll take their work but
that tests my technological ability sack
which you know is a little which one did
you want the county in one of you can
you do that it must be some better way
of doing this there's got to be a better
way we have no measures to lessen
crowding in state prison we have put in
a number of regulations and rules to
reduce the risk but reducing the prison
population we don't have we don't have
any way to do that right now
this is the slide you were talking about
positive cases
those measures and state prisons been
any different than those at nursing
homes or other facilities yeah I can get
you a full list of both there's been an
uptick of domestic violence cases from
people having to CO shelter together is
there any way or any assistance the
administration can provide for people
it's one eight hundred nine four to six
nine oh six that's our domestic violence
hotline women should know that they
don't have to stay in those situations
we will help them relocate you will help
them find safe shelter and if there is
an issue where you're an immediate harm
call 9-1-1 immediately I spoke to the
state police this morning there is a
reported uptick as you said some reports
as high as 15 to 20 percent it's
unacceptable on any day and I wanted
people to know that if every single case
that's reported the State Police is
going to investigate fully and bring the
full air of the law behind it let's take
one more how come you always ask the
last question I'm always curious is that
a French thing
it's French you think you don't want to
get in this scramble with these
aggressive Americans you also ask the
hardest questions is that a French thing
that you ask the most difficult
questions my brother the question my
brother is easy he's doing okay he this
is going to be a great public service
that he winds up doing it will have been
a miserable personal experience because
this virus is no joke at any age and
he's relatively young he's in good shape
but and he's had malaria before you know
he's he's not a crybaby by and large the
but this is the tough I mean it's tough
I talked to him several times a day
obviously it's tough he's doing fine but
it's tough to deal with but he's gonna
wind up doing a great public service
because all these questions or the
mystery about coronavirus what what if
this what if this what happens he is a
living example of living with
coronavirus right and he's up there and
he's talking about it so god bless him
and it demystifies it you know he can
talk you through it so I think that's
gonna wind up being a great public
service at the end of the day and as a
journalistic contribution I think it's
going to be great what did my father
teach me that is most helpful in this
situation you know he taught me so many
things on so many levels that it's hard
to say but he had tremendous stamina he
loved Winston Churchill never give up
never give up never give up that's where
we are he taught me to trust in love and
loves triumph over anger and hate and
self selfishness and we need love now we
need love as a people
am i seizing ventilators no I'm taking
excess equipment to save lives you know
it's about doing the right thing it's
about love and people will respond to
that in this state and in this country
and I think those are the two greatest
things this is hard
personally it's hard to go through this
all day and then it's hard to stay up
all night watching those numbers come in
on the number of deaths tick up and know
that you're in charge of the ship at
this time and
I don't shirk that responsibility at all
but I went through a lot of hard times
with him and eventually you go through
the darkness and you find the light and
we're going to find the light thank you
guys